hey you guys
time once again for the flickers of fear
series i'm very very excited to be doing
this one
because i've been wanting to see this
[ __ ] movie for like
two years maybe something like that
because i think what ended up happening
with this movie was that
probably i think one of the last movies
that tom and i saw in the theaters
before kobit
was the invisible man with elizabeth
moss
and i'm pretty sure that when we went to
see that movie
we saw the preview like the trailer for
this movie
and i maybe had seen it once or twice
before because i think i saw it at least
two times because i was like ooh
it's a 24 which i usually love their
movies and i was like that looks [ __ ]
good
so then obviously you know the theater
shut down and all this other crap
happened and i didn't really get around
to seeing it
i think it had sort of like a limited
release um it played at some festivals
like it released in the uk for a little
while and i think it even got um
a limited release in the us as well but
i didn't get to see it in the theater
and then finally finally they added it
on amazon prime
and i was able to finally watch it and
this is the 2019
british film st mod now if you guys saw
the trailer and i'm gonna say
i'm not i don't know if i'm gonna spoil
it spoil it because this is a pretty new
movie
and i know that it's gotten like a huge
amount of buzz and rightly so i think
because i'm gonna tell you like right
out front i
loved this movie i just thought it was
so amazing and it's just kind of like
the fact that it's
rose glasses debut like she wrote and
directed it and it's just
it i mean it's easily one of the best
horror movies i've seen in a very long
time
and you know that's not to say that
everyone is also going to love it
because like i said it's 8 24.
if you like a24 films that are kind of
like
you know it you know it's kind of a
cliche to say slow burn it kind of
is although not as much as some other
ones that i've seen and enjoyed
if you like the movies of oz perkins
like if you like the black coats
daughter
or um i am the pretty thing that lives
in the house this isn't
really exactly like that but it's the
same kind of vibe
you know what i'm getting at so if you
like that kind of stuff then you will
probably like this as well
even though it's not really all that
similar to those two movies if that
makes any sense i'm not sure that it
does
but like i said i don't know if i
necessarily want to spoil anything but
it's kind of hard to talk about without
spoiling it however
on the other hand i think this movie
is so much better if you don't really
know
where it's going now just from the
trailer
you could tell that it was about a girl
that was
you presumed a nurse and she was really
religious
and that was kind of all i knew about it
so i kind of liked that that's all i
knew
going into it because i had no idea what
was gonna transpire
like over the course of the movie and so
the whole thing like through the whole
thing
i was just sitting there kind of on the
edge of my seat
because i wasn't really sure like where
it was gonna go or what was gonna happen
or anything like that so i would suggest
if you wanna see this movie like going
into it pretty much
blind because it's just a lot better
that way and i think it's a lot more um
unsettling because you don't really know
what to expect but that said i am going
to have to like talk about it some
even though i'm going to try not to
spoil anything outright but
you know it's as i said and i usually
say this in my book reviews too it's
like if you don't want to know anything
about it obviously why are you watching
a video about it but
i mean uh ryan hollinger who i really
like if you uh don't know him he's like
an irish
movie reviewer and he generally does
horror movies and he does like real
in-depth uh reviews of them and he did
one of saint maude
and i was like i was dying because i
wanted to watch it but i was like i
wanted to watch this review but i was
like now i have to watch the movie first
because i knew because he usually spoils
it because he does like a really
in-depth uh discussion
but i did finally watch the movie so i
finally got to watch it so i was happy
about that
so this movie written and directed by
rose glass as i said and this is her
first
uh this is her feature film debut and
this tells the story
of a young woman named maud obviously
who's played by uh moravith clark
i hope hopefully i'm pronouncing that
right i did live in wales for a little
while so i do kind of
know how to pronounce some welsh words
but i think that's how you pronounce it
so at the very beginning there's a scene
where you're led to believe i mean you
kind of learn
little things about her over the course
of the movie like about her past and
stuff
but i like that it wasn't spelled out i
mean you really this is another one that
you really really have to pay attention
to everything that's going on like some
of the flashbacks that she has
some of the stuff that she says um some
of the stuff that other people say to
her
because a lot of the her past and uh her
thought processes are kind of
illuminated through that
rather than it you know just being like
really obvious
so at the very beginning you can tell
she's in her nurse's uniform and she's
sitting in a corner
and then she's just covered with blood
and then there's um you know a patient
that is obviously dead like with blood
dripping down so you're led to assume
that something that she did caused this
person's
death um and like i said that's kind of
all
the information you're giving on given
on that but like little bits of it come
out like as the movie goes on
so uh some little time later i think it
was like a year or something like that
she has gotten a new position as a
private care nurse
for this woman named amanda now amanda
is 49 years old
uh she used to be a dancer and
choreographer of some renown
like she knows you know she's been she
lived in new york and london
and she was kind of you know one of
those kind of people is up in the you
know like art scene and everything like
that
however now she has stage four uh
lymphoma i believe
it's a cancer of the spinal column or
something like that and she is
dying so she's had a series of
uh live-in care nurses to take care of
her while she in her convalescence you
know so mom
shows up and there's kind of an
interesting dynamic between these two
women pretty much immediately
because as you as the movie goes on
you learn that mod after the
tragedy which happened where one of her
patients died like i said i think it was
a year
or so maybe a little more than a year
prior to the events of the movie
she because of the trauma she not only
uh
ended up losing her position at the
hospital that she worked at
but she also had um a conversion
and she becomes like super catholic
i mean you know what i mean and it's
kind of like one of those things where
uh you know the
it's like a new convert and they're like
really really hardcore about it
so she lives in this she lived in this
like shabby little room she's got like a
shrine
and uh everything so she
thinks i guess that because she lived
kind of a desolute dissolute life
prior to her the patient dying under her
care she deals with her trauma by
essentially like giving her life over to
for to a new faith and becoming really
really hardcore about it
so as this relationship between
her patient and her develops
she becomes convinced that
her mission in life that god has told
her
that she is supposed to save
amanda's soul because amanda is an
atheist
and doesn't believe that there's
anything in the afterlife she is afraid
of dying
and she's kind of like it's really funny
because
in a very early scene where mod first
arrives at the
mansion and she relieves the other nurse
um you know she asks the other nurse
she's kind of like well you know what's
what's amanda like or something like
that and the other nurse she's kind of
dismissive because she just wants to
leave she's like
she's a bit of a [ __ ] that's like pretty
much how she describes her
so amanda she doesn't seem she's not a
terrible person
but she is kind of dismissive
toward maude's um religious beliefs
while still kind of being afraid of
dying and
so she she's kind of almost like a
little bit sarcastic like she's kind of
teasing her
about her beliefs but mod doesn't really
register that
so as the movie goes on she becomes as i
said more and more convinced that
this is her mission in life is she's
supposed to save this woman's soul
before she dies
and it doesn't quite go
the way that you think it might
so like i said i don't want to spoil too
much about this
but i really i mean i thought this was
just a fantastic movie
is it a horror movie yeah it does have
some body or like some kind of gross
body horror like people do get killed
uh there's some gross [ __ ] with her
doing like self uh
you know when she like burns her own
hand and looks like pulling the skin off
so there's like some gross [ __ ] in it
it's mostly though
it's kind of like a character study
of mod and it's a this is this is kind
of a spoiler to say this but
her increasing delusion
because as this as the movie goes on you
know she
ends up and as i said i'm kind of
getting into like mild spoiler territory
here
but about at the halfway point of the
movie she ends up getting uh
fired from amanda's care uh and
rightfully so because she did something
bad
but after that she kind of has a
backslide
into what she used to be like before her
conversion
and uh you know just from her
interactions with other people and the
way she's acting
she was um kind of a party girl like she
would go out to the bars and drink and
she'd just like take random men home and
stuff like that
so there's a lot of like little hints
about that you know throughout the movie
i
think there's even i don't even really
realize this until i was watching like a
couple other analyses of it
but there's one very brief scene where
she's kind of laying on her bed and you
can kind of see part of her stomach and
it looks like there's kind of scars or
like stretch marks or something like
that
so i don't know if you're if you're led
to believe that she got pregnant at some
point
because she was you know she could
because she was promiscuous or something
like that but it's
it's left very ambiguous but it is kind
of implied during the film
that you know she lived this kind of
like i don't
know like [ __ ] or anything like that
but she was like you know
she used to hang out with people and go
out and drinking and you know
sleeping around and stuff like that and
for whatever reason after
she lost her job and after all of that
happened uh she kind of went into a
downward spiral which led to her
conversion to catholicism and her
getting like really fervid about it so a
bunch of other stuff
like she one of the things that she does
before she gets fired from amanda's
thing is that amanda has had uh she has
this
lady friend named carol who comes over
and um she essentially like pays her for
sex right
so obviously maude does not approve of
this um
i don't know if she doesn't approve of
the of the paying for sex or because
it's two women
it's but it doesn't really matter she
just doesn't approve of it and she
actually kind of goes behind amanda's
back and like tells carol to leave
because she's like we're doing something
important here like i have to save her
soul and all this other kind of stuff
and carol's like yeah sure okay whatever
and the thing about it is that maude is
a character and like i said this is
a very intense character study she's
sympathetic but she's also awful
and i mean she's awful because she's
mentally ill and she's very delusional
so in that way she's very sympathetic
and it does seem like
after her conversion she has a very very
difficult time
relating to people it's almost kind of
like people now seem like aliens to her
um you know there's one scene where
she's in a bar and like she's
just kind of looking at people and
everybody just looks like kind of weird
and distorted and everything like
she can't really deal with the real
world anymore because her mental illness
is progressing to such an extent
that she doesn't feel like on the same
plane with people because now she feels
like she's
on this great mission and that god talks
to her and all these other things
so as i said it's i will say that it's
actually this is a
admirably a short film it's only an hour
and 24 minutes long
it's kind of so i like that it told its
story in that like succinct amount of
time
and the movie really sustains
a sense of just this really it has a
really
unsettling vibe to it especially go if
you go in
go into it not really knowing because as
the movie goes
on like the imagery gets weirder and
weirder and you're just kind of sitting
there going wait is this is there really
supernatural [ __ ] going on or is this
just how she's perceiving things
so if you don't know where it's going it
just kind of like just gets creepier and
creepier and i mean her
uh performance uh more with
clark's performance is just so so good i
mean she's just so
like the physicality of it just like her
facial expressions
and and there's a couple of like really
creepy scenes like kind of
you know i hate to like cheapen them by
calling them jump scares
but there are a couple moments in it
that just like
came out of nowhere and just like scared
the [ __ ] crap out of me because i
wasn't expecting it
like especially one of the scenes near
the end and i will say that
the very very end of this like the
last couple frames of the movie was
really like a punch in the gut you know
what i mean it was just kind of like you
especially if you really got immersed in
the movie and immersed in her character
you know it's kind of cool because it
kind of leads you along this one path
like of ambiguity and stuff like that
but then the end of it like definitively
you know no it was this and just that
final like i said it's almost like a
jump scare because you're not really
expecting it just kind of pops out and
it's gone like a couple frames later
but it was just it's so so effective and
i
i just think that's so great that that
that it ended like that and it was just
like this kind of self-contained
story about this this poor young woman
who obviously had some trauma in her
past and needed some help
some people did reach out to help her
later on but by that point it was
probably too late because she was too
far
gone and she had really taken it upon
herself
to think that she was kind of god's
emissary on earth and this is what she
was supposed to do and
you know damn anybody who got in her way
kind of thing which
like i said that's never a good thing
when a person comes to that
uh kind of conclusion but as i said you
can still kind of sympathize with her
because she's clearly
so lonely and so mentally ill that she
can't really
help it so this movie is now on amazon
prime i think you can also get it on
blu-ray but maybe only in the uk
i was watching um another horror channel
drum dumbs
and somebody had sent him the blu-ray
from uh
from the uk because he said it was hard
to get in the u.s so i don't know about
now but um it's on amazon prime if you
have a subscription you can watch it on
there
in the us i'm not sure about other
countries but
like i said if you like any of a24 stuff
like i said you know elevated horror
whatever they want to call it and
and you liked you know things like the
witch or things like the black coats
daughter things like that this is kind
of the same
vibe as that it's not like i said it's a
slow burn but
it's not that slow and some of the stuff
that happens in it
like it does have some pretty horrific
imagery and the implications of it are
kind of horrific too like i said if you
but you really have to this is one of
those movies that you really need to
like
kind of focus your whole attention on it
and like become immersed
in this girl's character and in her
world
and it has a lot more impact uh if you
do that
but yeah i'm really really glad that i
finally finally got to see this
movie because was it i saw the trailer
like two years ago and i was like oh man
that looks really good and i really want
to see it
and then i never got to see it and then
finally it came to amazon prime and i
was like super excited so i was afraid
too that it's like because i've been
waiting to see it for so long that it
would be
disappointing because you know i i'd
heard so much hype about it and
everything like that
but it really wasn't it was actually
like much better than i was expecting it
to be but
you know as i said if you don't like
kind of slow burn horror movies you
don't like character study type of
movies then you probably won't like it
but
i do kind of feel like you know if you
do like that kind of stuff then you'll
probably probably really like it i mean
i thought it was
fantastic and i just i can't wait to see
what rose glass does next because i
think she's kind of
she's going to be like another big name
and some uh upcoming horror films i hope
because this one was
just a pretty dynamite uh debut gotta
say
so uh yeah check it out if it sounds
like something that you would enjoy
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear and i will see you on the next one
bye